El 12 de febrero de 2014, la ciudad de Caracas
estalló en protestas.
Venezuela, estaba sufriendo una de las crisis
económicas más importantes de toda su historia.
La inflación ya estaba despuntando, la inseguridad
y la violencia campaban a sus anchas, y los
productos básicos eran cada vez más y más
escasos.
Miles de manifestantes, estudiantes y trabajadores
se rebelaron contra el gobierno. Las marchas
duraron semanas. Y, entre todos ellos, hubo
un personaje que supuso un antes y un después
en la historia política de Venezuela: Leopoldo
López.
Leopoldo López fue, por así decirlo, el
primer gran revolucionario contra el gobierno
de Maduro. Fue precisamente él, quien alentó
la oleada de protestas ocurrida en 2014.
Y a diferencia de muchos otros políticos
de la oposición, Leopoldo López estuvo al
pie del cañón en las marchas. Liderando
y abanderando la manifestación contra el
régimen.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué es Leopoldo tan
importante en nuestra historia?
Pues es importante por la siguiente noticia.
(11/09/2015: Leopoldo López, 18 meses en
prisión por incitar a la protesta. El País)
Después de las protestas de 2014, el gobierno
Venezolano mandó arrestar a Leopoldo López
bajo los cargos de instigación a delinquir,
asociacionismo delictivo, daños contra la
propiedad pública… y en definitiva, una
retahíla de acusaciones que, en realidad,
eran una manera de maquillar lo evidente:
Leopoldo López fue detenido básicamente
por ser una molestia para el gobierno. Era
un opositor con poder que había que quitarse
de encima. Y el régimen bolivariano, no dudó
ni un segundo en hacerlo.
Sea como sea, el arresto de Leopoldo no fue
la única calamidad antidemocrática pertrechada
por el régimen chavista.
Al mismo tiempo, el gobierno de Maduro usó
los servicios de inteligencia para perseguir
a multitud de opositores, torturó a rivales
políticos, y como muchos recordaréis, asesinó
a decenas de manifestantes en plena calle.
(23/02/2014: Ascienden a 10 las muertes en
las protestas en Venezuela mientras continúan
las manifestaciones. RTVE)
En 2014 se cruzaron todas las líneas rojas
que exige la democracia, y amigos, eso tuvo
consecuencias internacionales muy directas.
(Obama firma una ley de sanciones dirigida
a los oficiales venezolanos. Reuters)
En marzo de 2014, tan solo un mes después
del inicio de las protestas lideradas por
Leopoldo López, y de su posterior encarcelamiento,
el Congreso de los EE. UU de común acuerdo
con la Casa Blanca de Barack Obama, aprobó
una ley para sancionar a los líderes venezolanos
responsables de violar los derechos humanos
en su país.
(Al principio las sanciones se dirigieron
contra personas en concreto, congelando sus
cuentas corrientes y limitando sus negocios
en EE. UU.
Por ejemplo, uno de los sancionados fue Antonio
José Benavides, comandante de la guardia
nacional y responsable de represión en las
protestas contra el gobierno.
Otro sancionado fue Gustavo Enrique González,
director del servicio de inteligencia venezolano,
y asociado al espionaje de opositores, y a
multitud de detenciones extrajudiciales.
La pregunta es: ¿Qué pretendía el Congreso
estadounidense? ¿Cuál era el plan que la
Administración Obama había puesto sobre
la mesa?
Pues lo que pretendían era castigar personalmente
a los represores sin castigar al país en
su conjunto ni alentar tampoco un cambio de
régimen. Obama simplemente quiso desincentivar
las malas actitudes de los miembros del régimen
para que estas no se repitieran.)
Sin embargo, en el año 2017 todo cambió.
Un nuevo inquilino llegó a la Casa Blanca
y cambió el panorama internacional de golpe
y porrazo. Aquí hablamos por supuesto de
Donald Trump.
Donald Trump pasará a la historia como el
presidente de la guerra comercial contra China,
por su mítico “Stop the count”, o por
el prometido y nunca terminado muro en la
frontera de México.
No obstante, hay otro elemento que distinguió
la política de Trump, un elemento al que
no se le suele prestar mucha atención: aquí
estamos hablando de su política de sanciones.
Tras llegar al poder, Donald Trump se hinchó
a repartir a diestro y siniestro sanciones
inter B nacionales. En total, se contaron
más de 3.900. Por comparar, ningún presidente
anterior había superado las 700.
Por supuesto, Venezuela no iba a ser una excepción
en este reparto de sanciones, y en el año
2017, sucedió esto:
(Trump impone sanciones sobre Venezuela. Reuters)
Las nuevas sanciones de Trump contra Venezuela
fueron mucho más duras que las de Obama.
Porque ¿Os acordáis de que Obama tan solo
castigó a algunas personas del régimen en
concreto, no?
Pues Trump fue mucho más allá.
Trump bloqueó por completo el acceso del
gobierno venezolano al sistema financiero
de EE. UU. Y además, cortó por lo sano la
repatriación de los beneficios que las empresas
del gobierno venezolano obtenían en los EE.
UU. Y sí, estamos hablando sobre todo de
PDVSA.
En resumen, las nuevas sanciones de Trump
dejaron a Maduro sin poder acceder a los beneficios,
y sin acceso a nuevo crédito para costear
su gobierno.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué Trump hizo todo
esto?
Pues… Básicamente, lo hizo para ahogar
al gobierno de Venezuela, para dejarle sin
recursos, debilitarlo al máximo, y así,
facilitar un cambio de régimen.
C1 (“Nuestras sanciones se han centrado
en cortar cada fuente de ingresos con las
que Maduro sostiene su régimen totalitario
y criminal. Donald Trump en un comunicado
de la Casa Blanca.)
Como veis, a diferencia de Obama, que simplemente
quería desincentivar las malas prácticas,
Donald Trump quiso dar un vuelco completo
al tablero político de Venezuela. Su objetivo
fue derrocar al gobierno de Maduro.
Pero amigos, la cosa no quedó ahí.
En el año 2019, un nuevo jugador entró en
escena: Juan Guaidó.
Tan solo dos años después del paquete de
sanciones de Trump, el gobierno de Venezuela
se enfrentó a su mayor momento de fragilidad
hasta la fecha.
Juan Guaidó, líder de la oposición, se
autoproclamó presidente de Venezuela, y suscitó
una rebelión que prometió acabar con el
régimen de maduro de una vez por todas.
Evidentemente, EE. UU. y Donald Trump dieron
todo su apoyo a Guaidó.
Por una parte, le reconocieron como el legítimo
presidente de Venezuela.
Pero por la otra, aplicaron un nuevo paquete
de sanciones, si cabe, todavía más duro
que el anterior.
En concreto, estas nuevas sanciones, cortaron
por lo sano las compras estadounidenses de
petróleo venezolano.
Y no solo eso, sino que el gobierno de Trump
prácticamente obligó a otros países a hacer
un enorme boicot con el que dejar a Venezuela
sin compradores para su crudo.
(Estados Unidos ha ordenado a refinerías
y comerciantes de todo el mundo que corten
sus compras de petróleo en Venezuela. Si
no lo hacen, enfrentarán sanciones. Reuters)
Ya sabéis, el dólar estadounidense es la
moneda internacional por excelencia. El dólar
es responsable de casi el 90% de todas las
transacciones económicas a nivel global.
Y eso es algo que le permite al gobierno gringo
amenazar a países y empresas extranjeras
para que colaboren en su política de sanciones.
Básicamente, o estás del lado de EE. UU.,
o estás del lado de sus enemigos.
Pues bien, llegado el 2019, el gobierno de
Venezuela se encontró con serios problemas
económicos tras no poder acceder al sistema
financiero estadounidense, perder los beneficios
de parte de sus empresas, y encima, sufrir
un duro embargo de petróleo por parte de
EE. UU. y de sus aliados.
¿Conclusión?
Pues la conclusión… es que, en principio,
todas las sanciones no sirvieron para nada.
El gobierno de Maduro sigue ahí, tanto Leopoldo
López como Juan Guaidó han pasado a la completa
irrelevancia. Y siendo francos: no parece
que esto vaya a cambiar en ningún momento
cercano. [Por mucho que nos prometan elecciones
limpias en 2024]
Pero, ¿Y si os dijera que todavía hay más?
¿Y si os dijera que las sanciones permitieron
a Maduro consolidarse en el poder, en lugar
de debilitarlo?
Pues sí, tal cual como lo escucháis. Y no
solo eso, sino que según apuntan algunas
teorías, las sanciones pudieron ser, en realidad,
el origen de la terrible crisis de hiperinflación
qué sufrió Venezuela durante estos últimos
años.
La pregunta es ¿Cómo se explica todo esto?
¿Qué hay detrás de lo que acabamos de contar?
¿De verdad fueron tan catastróficas las
sanciones?
Pues… Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver. ¿Y sabéis
qué? Para hablar de ello en esta ocasión
tenemos un invitado. Óscar todo tuyo.
(EL CASTIGO QUE SE CONVIRTIÓ EN PREMIO)
La primera pregunta que debemos responder
en todo este asunto es: ¿Cuáles fueron las
consecuencias de las sanciones en Venezuela?
¿Es verdad que fueron las causantes de la
crisis hiperinflacionaria de 2017?
Pues, vayamos por orden.
Como hemos dicho, el primer paquete de sanciones
de Donald Trump consistió en cortar el acceso
tanto del gobierno venezolano como de las
empresas públicas al mercado financiero estadounidense.
En principio, esto es un problema que solo
debería afectar al estado, sin embargo, me
temo que la cosa fue mucho más allá, porque,
os pregunto:
¿Cuál es la principal fuente de ingresos
de la economía venezolana?
Efectivamente, el petróleo. La cuestión
es que el petróleo Venezolano está monopolizado
por la empresa del gobierno PDVSA.
Y resulta que cuando Trump cortó el acceso
al mercado financiero del Gobierno, PDVSA
perdió el acceso a créditos con los que
pagar proveedores, no pudo financiar fácilmente
sus inversiones, ni tampoco llevar a cabo
tareas de mantenimiento, o de reestructuración
de su deuda.
Todo esto, junto a una pésima gestión, a
la colación de miles de amiguetes y a la
huida al extranjero de los mejores profesionales
de la empresa, hicieron que la producción
de crudo se desplomara. Hablamos de una pérdida
milmillonaria.
Como ya imaginaréis, esto supuso un duro
golpe para el gobierno bolivariano, pero sobre
todo supuso un mazazo para los propios ciudadanos.
(Y es que, veréis, para que Venezuela pueda
importar productos como medicinas o alimentos,
necesita tener divisas internacionales. Divisas
que obtiene y obtenía principalmente con
la venta de petróleo.
Eso significa, que cuando la exportación
de petróleo baja, la disponibilidad de productos
esenciales como los medicamentos también
se reduce.
Y esto, es especialmente preocupante teniendo
en cuenta que Venezuela, por ejemplo, tan
solo es capaz de producir en torno al 10%
de todos los inputs que necesita para garantizar
el suministro de productos farmacéuticos.
Cosa que, quizá en menor medida, también
se aplica a alimentos, ropa, equipos informáticos
o cualquier otro tipo de importación.)
Y claro, si a esto le sumamos el embargo de
petróleo en 2019, el resultado, según algunos
estudios pesimistas, es que más de 300.000
personas estuvieron en riesgo de quedarse
sin tratamiento médico. Aumentaron las muertes
en más de 40.000, y el consumo calórico
de las familias cayó en picado.
Pero eso, eso no es todo.
Al perder el dinero del petróleo, el gobierno
de Venezuela se quedó sin divisas con las
que respaldar el Bolívar, la moneda Venezolana.
Y de nuevo, según muchas teorías esto fue
lo que provocó la hiperinflación venezolana
de 2017.
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir esto que Venezuela
se fue a pique por culpa de las sanciones
de EE. UU.? ¿Son las teorías pesimistas
realmente ciertas?
Pues, no vayamos tan de prisa.
Vamos a ver. Es cierto que las sanciones estadounidenses
supusieron un golpe para las familias venezolanas.
Negarlo simplemente sería absurdo.
Ahora bien, lo cierto es que los problemas
de Venezuela difícilmente se originaron a
partir de ellas.
Por ejemplo, es cierto que las sanciones pusieron
difícil a PDVSA poder financiarse para pagar
a sus proveedores.
Pero es que en realidad, ya mucho antes de
la aplicación de las sanciones, PDVSA ya
tenía muchos pero que muchísimos problemas
para poder acceder a crédito.
En concreto, para el año 2017, la deuda de
PDVSA alcanzaba a los 30.000 millones de dólares.
Era una empresa en ruinas, en quiebra, y los
inversores internacionales se fiaban poco
de su capacidad de pago.
Tanto es así, qué empresas como Goldman
Sachs tan solo estuvieron dispuestas a financiar
PDVSA a tipos de interés disparatadísimos,
cercanos al 48%.
Vamos, que los problemas de PDVSA con la financiación,
muy probablemente habrían surgido con o sin
las sanciones.
Por otra parte, hay que tener en cuenta que
la producción de petróleo en Venezuela ya
venía cayendo dramáticamente respecto al
conjunto de la OPEP, desde, por lo menos,
el año 2015. Dos años antes de las sanciones
de Trump.
La culpa estuvo en una gestión pésima, costes
excesivos, y por supuesto la corrupción al
más puro estilo bolivariano. La producción
de crudo se desplomó por culpa del gobierno,
no por culpa de las sanciones, que, en todo
caso, simplemente empeoraron una tendencia
que ya era baja de por sí.
Ahora bien: ¿Qué hay de la falta de acceso
a medicamentos y comida?
Pues de nuevo, más de lo mismo.
La capacidad de ingesta calórica de los Venezolanos,
o la importación de medicamentos, también
se desplomaron mucho antes de la llegada de
las sanciones internacionales.
En conclusión, aunque las sanciones pudieron
suponer un empeoramiento de la crisis Venezolana,
y del nivel de vida de los venezolanos, no
fueron su origen ni muchísimo menos.
Pero, sea como sea, lo cierto, es que sí
que hay un factor de las sanciones que pudo
perjudicar muy gravemente al país.
Y ese factor es el que os hemos comentado
antes: Las sanciones pudieron ser la herramienta
perfecta para mantener a Maduro en el poder.
¿Cómo es eso posible?
Pues… ¡Prestad mucha atención!
(¿SANCIÓN O BENDICIÓN? )
La teoría original de las sanciones, dice
que sancionar a un país sirve para dejar
a su gobierno sin recursos económicos, y
así, dar pie a una revolución popular que
acabe con él.
En el caso de Venezuela, los componentes de
esta estrategia estaban muy claros.
EE. UU. limitó los recursos financieros a
Maduro y a sus empresas, embargó la compra
de petróleo, y mientras tanto, apoyó a Juan
Guaidó para encabezar la revolución contra
el régimen.
No obstante, el resultado fue todo lo contrario
a lo esperado. Maduro acabó siendo más fuerte
que nunca, y Guaidó, acabó siendo, y siento
mucho decirlo, una figura poco relevante en
toda esta historia. La teoría original de
las sanciones fracasó.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué lo hizo?
Pues, de hecho, fracasó, porque la teoría…
Está mal. Lo cierto es que las sanciones
económicas no suelen funcionar para subvertir
gobiernos dictatoriales, ni mucho menos, para
garantizar los derechos humanos.
Es más, en un estudio del politólogo Dursen
Peksen, que contempló una muestra de 95 países
que sufrieron sanciones entre 1981 y el año
2000, se encontró, que las sanciones aumentaron
los abusos de poder, aumentaron los crímenes
contra los derechos humanos, y en definitiva,
consiguieron todo lo contrario a lo que pretendían
Es como si las sanciones, en vez de derrocar
A LOS gobiernos tiránicos, les dieran más
poder.
Esto es algo que, además, otros estudios
han ratificado, e incluso han llegado a demostrar
que, cuanto más duras sean las sanciones,
y cuantos más países participen en ellas,
más contraproducentes serán.
Ojo, esto no quiere decir que sancionar siempre
sea contraproducente, o que no tenga sentido.
Por ejemplo, en el caso de la guerra de Ucrania,
el objetivo de las sanciones fue esencialmente
debilitar a corto, medio y largo plazo las
capacidades militares y económicas de Rusia,
no propiciar un cambio hacia un régimen democrático.
En ese escenario las sanciones sí tienen
sentido.
Por eso, cuando decimos que las sanciones
son contraproducentes, hablamos de que no
sirven para derrocar gobiernos y establecer
democracias, tal y como se pretendía en Venezuela.
La pregunta es: ¿Por qué?
Pues principalmente por dos razones.
La primera es que cuando un país recibe sanciones,
los gobiernos dictatoriales, efectivamente,
pierden muchos recursos, como por ejemplo,
los ingresos del petróleo.
El problema es que para compensar esta falta
de recursos, los dictadores empiezan a exprimir
y a controlar mucho más el resto de la economía
del país. Y un ejemplo muy claro de ello,
lo podemos ver en Irak.
Veréis, en el año 1995, las Naciones Unidas
establecieron duras sanciones contra el régimen
de Saddam Hussein en Irak.
En concreto, limitaron la cantidad de petróleo
que podía exportar el país, le dejaron lo
justo y suficiente para que el gobierno pudiera
importar alimentos para sus ciudadanos.
¿Y cuál fue la respuesta de Saddam Hussein?
Pues, el dictador Irakí empezó a controlar
por completo la distribución de alimentos.
Prohibió el libre mercado a los ciudadanos,
y distribuyó la comida mediante cartillas
de racionamiento.
A partir de entonces, cada familia en Irak
tuvo que registrarse en una especie de libro
de raciones alimenticias, y gracias a eso,
Saddam Hussein obtuvo una base de datos tremenda
de todos los ciudadanos irakíes constantemente
actualizada.
Una base de datos, que por supuesto, el gobierno
pudo utilizar para reprimir a opositores políticos,
para controlar quién comía o dejaba de comer,
y en definitiva, para aumentar su poder tiránico.
Si lo pensáis, sin las sanciones, Saddam
Hussein nunca habría tenido el incentivo,
ni quizá la legitimidad para controlar la
distribución de alimentos, y, por tanto,
no habría aumentado su poder.
Digamos que al recortar los recursos del gobierno,
los dictadores se ven obligados a subyugar
todavía más a sus ciudadanos con tal de
seguir a flote.
Ahora bien, todavía hay una segunda razón
por la que las sanciones pueden ayudar a los
dictadores, y aumentar su represión: La razón
del chivo expiatorio.
En este vídeo, hemos hablado de las teorías
que culpan a las sanciones de EE. UU. de provocar
la hiperinflación, el hambre y la crisis
en Venezuela.
Estas teorías son falsas, tal y como hemos
visto.
Sin embargo, el gobierno Venezolano ha insistido
en numerosas ocasiones en que EE. UU., y sus
sanciones, tienen la culpa de la crisis:
(Maduro culpa a las restricciones impuestas
por Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea del
decrecimiento venezolano. Atalayar)
(Maduro culpa a EE.UU. de que Venezuela
perdiera 99% de los ingresos en divisas en
seis años. ABC)
Como veis, las sanciones son una muy buena
forma con la que los dictadores pueden desviar
la atención de los problemas reales de su
país.
Es más fácil culpar al malvado agresor,
al imperialista yankee asesino, de tu colapso
económico, que asumir la culpa y perder legitimidad.
El problema de todo esto, es que mucha gente
cree las palabras de los dictadores. Y las
sanciones sirven como una forma de hacer ver
al dictador como un gran líder que lucha
contra las amenazas de los países sancionadores.
Algo que, por cierto, es muy habitual en América
Latina. ¿Recordais el tema del embargo? Pues…
Eso.
(“En Cuba, por ejemplo, Castro describió
las sanciones estadounidenses como un intento
imperialista de atentar contra la independencia
y la integridad del pueblo cubano. Las sanciones,
por lo tanto, permitieron a Castro desviar
la atención pública de los problemas internos
del régimen comunista a la amenaza externa
planteada por las sanciones. Así, a medida
que Castro se convirtió en un líder heroico
que luchaba contra el poder imperialista,
la coerción económica le facilitó la justificación
de su régimen opresor.”)
En resumen, las sanciones pueden disparar
los abusos de dictadores por dos vías: obligándoles
a reprimir para extraer nuevos recursos, y
legitimando sus acciones, culpando de todo
a los países sancionadores.
Aunque, visto esto, hay algo que no queda
del todo claro: ¿Por qué motivo entonces
muchos países siguen aplicando sanciones
para derrocar regímenes dictatoriales?
Pues aquí hay por lo menos tres hipótesis.
(La primera es que aunque las sanciones, en
promedio, no son exitosas, en algunos casos
pueden acabar dando sus frutos.
La segunda, es que las sanciones pueden tener
objetivos ocultos más allá de propiciar
la democracia y salvaguardar los derechos
humanos. Por ejemplo, no sería descabellado
que las sanciones en Venezuela tuvieran como
objetivo paralelo evitar el auge de los movimientos
socialistas revolucionarios en el resto de
América Latina.
Y la tercera, es que aunque las sanciones
no funcionen demasiado una vez impuestas,
en realidad tienen un enorme poder disuasorio.
Es decir, ningún gobierno de ningún país
quiere ser sancionado, de forma que para evitar
sanciones, evitan pasarse de la raya.
En ese sentido, las sanciones funcionan más
como un castigo y una disuasión, que como
una herramienta correctora. )
Sea como sea, cabe destacar que las sanciones
no son la única forma de castigar, o desincentivar,
las malas prácticas de los gobiernos tiránicos.
Recientemente, se han propuesto alternativas
como los sistemas zanahoria. Sí, zanahoria,
como el palo y la zanahoria.
Esta estrategia consiste en establecer incentivos
positivos a los gobiernos poco democráticos
para comportarse adecuadamente. Aquí hablamos
de concesión de créditos baratos, ayudas
en forma de subvenciones, o la participación
en clubes internacionales. Sería una filosofía
de recompensa más que de castigo.
Sea como sea, y visto todo esto, ahora el
turno es para vosotros:
¿Pensáis que la política de sanciones en
Venezuela estuvo bien diseñada? ¿Creéis
que Donald Trump se excedió, y perjudicó
al pueblo venezolano de forma innecesaria?
¿Qué haríais vosotros para incentivar comportamientos
democráticos en países poco respetuosos
con los derechos civiles?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.